quando tinha 27 anos recebeu um presente
eu perdi meu primo ele morreu de um
câncer simples de tratar mas demorou
para ser descoberto e aquilo foi muito
importante na minha vida pelo seguinte
além de perder alguém muito querido que
uma nova vida toda juntos muitos planos
é eu transponho aquela situação para a
minha realidade naquele momento que eu
quero dizer com isso
eu percebi que também podia morrer
incrível né que todo mundo aqui está
sujeito a isso
o momento mas e se essa relação íntima
com a morte
essa flerte com a finitude foi
profundamente transformador pra mim é a
partir daquele momento eu passei a
principalmente revisitar as minhas
escolhas
o primeiro passo foi um caminho natural
que acho que o meu padrão fazer terapia
para buscar a terapia e esse processo eu
acabei fazendo psicanálise eram quatro
vezes por semana foi muito mais intenso
do que imaginava e junto com isso passei
também a fazer reflexões mais profundas
sobre as mesmas coisas na vida que está
levando e quatro anos depois tive um avc
no estádio estava no jogo do são paulo
na semifinal da libertadores sabota
sobrando gente então é super tranquilo
não era essa questão não estava nervoso
e tinha uma vez e eu vencer não foi leve
porque parece que só por não ter
consequências
enfim não foi não foi de 40% cerebelo
gente que perde 10% do cerebelo e acaba
ficando já fala fica se com movimentos
comprometidos enfim
é não foi uma coisa leve mas foi super
importante a sequela que eu tive na
verdade foi inversa e o meu cérebro
ricocheteou e eu virei um gênio como
vocês podem ver além de ser um fenômeno
ela me colocou em movimento
então o que o que até até ii até aquele
momento era uma era um movimento interno
de reflexão interna onde as pessoas que
conviveram comigo não percebi muito o
que estava mudando mesmo porque as
minhas atitudes da minha relação com o
mundo era mais ou menos a mesma me
colocar em movimento e lançou um segundo
momento de reflexão onde eu também segui
o momento 11 processo convencional de
romper com completar fazendo trabalho
inclusive o executivo da empresa
ganhando muito bem na vida bastante
estável com seus dilemas como todas as
profissões têm mas neste momento eu
resolvi lançar e aí começa a fazer
milhares de cursos desde percussão até
cursos de cabala rei que a meditação
filosofia pratico yoga e nesse processo
incluiu uma passagem pela índia
resolvi ir para a índia e na índia
fiquei eu decidi ficar
fazia parte do domingo o roteiro passar
um tempo não acham
pra quem não sabe eu acho que é um lugar
de reclusão estudo
no meu caso de prática de yoga também
lá aconteceu uma coisa engraçada porque
não encontrei a paz de espírito que
tanto buscava contra em uma quietude e
aquilo me desconcertou porque não estava
nos meus planos
viver e encontrar o rapaz tão cedo mas
ao mesmo tempo o clube colocou num
dilema profundo por que eu deveria
seguir esse caminho da espiritualidade
você meu destino era nesse mundo
material e à conclusão que cheguei
depois de muito sol ou seja a paz
interna que eu conquistei por alguns
dias
logo perdi porque vive esse drama
interno
depois de alguns dias à conclusão que
cheguei foi que o desafio não estava no
mundo transcendente
muita gente não gosta de mim nunca o
mundo da matéria precise mas muito
transcendente já tá aí tá pronto não
precisa de ninguém
então decidi voltar pro brasil nós vamos
derrotar o brasil decide não deixar de
voltar a fazer é em montar uma empresa
por que não montar uma empresa o ficou
bastante claro pra mim que na sociedade
a gente via o as empresas têm um papel
protagonista ou o central na construção
do tecido social de fato que eu quero
dizer com isso é muito mais do que as
ongs igrejas já teve um papel
preponderante o mesmo governos sete
governos totalitários claro as empresas
de fato influenciam a construção da
sociedade muito mais do que qualquer
outro setor
e nesse processo de reflexão também
incluiu uma vivência uma passagem uma
com uma me aproximei bastante do mundo
social do terceiro setor e nesse lugar
eu descobri que eu encontrei o que
faltava para fechar contra a minha
cabeça sobre as pessoas que trabalhavam
por um propósito uma causa é de certa
forma se nutriam e preenche a alma que
justificavam que diferentemente de quem
trabalhava para no final do mês
receber um salário essas pessoas que
acordava de manhã e que no final do dia
faziam coisas que de alguma forma
estavam relacionadas
o que de fato é importante para elas com
causas que de fato relevante pra elas
nutre uma alma e provavelmente não é
feliz é e aí comecei a me conectar com
vários movimentos no mundo que também
pensava assim encontrei alguns e 11
movimentos que mais me empolguei quando
eu encontrei foi um movimento de
empresas de que não sei se vocês sabem
mas as empresas buscam referir o que é
sucesso
então fazer sucesso causando mal para a
sociedade é um sucesso relativo
então se você constrói algo como empresa
que faz mal ao seu consumidor ou faz mal
pro os colaboradores ou mal pro
fornecedores da comunidade é um sucesso
entre aspas né
é tão de sucesso vendendo cerveja
proficiência é um sucesso das empresas
não tem muito valor
é um outro então para decidir montar um
negócio
eu passei a refletir quais quais eram os
temas que mais pessoal vão pra mim que
de fato importava pra mim é um tema
recorrente era água
eu tenho uma relação de ser algo com a
água adoro água no nado
adoro entrar no mar adoro chuva ou tomar
banho
eu acho que todo ser humano tem isso é
uma coisa natural da natureza humana e
eu queria muito entender como é que
segundo ela funcionava
eu já havia ouvido falar dessa crise da
água que não é uma coisa recente está se
tornando mais emergente porque a gente
não toma decisões então atitudes
eu queria entender como é que se
contaminam a água é quais são os tipos
de contaminação pela casa carga sofre
com as tecnologias disponíveis para o
tratamento eu queria saber como se trata
a água enfim aí fazia muito sentido
trabalhar com um com água e aí eu decidi
montar uma pequena empresa que
basicamente coleta e trata efluentes de
terceiros ou seja as indústrias usam a
água a gente vai lá com o nosso
caminhãozinho retira sabe trata na
estação que fica no interior de são
paulo é porque as empresas precisam de
pedir tratar fora e não tratam
localmente né
são vários motivos um deles é não tem
espaço ou uma frente muito complexo para
tratar ela não tem vontade nem vocação
para fazer isso
e até para tranquilizar um pouco vou
contar uma história de um caso recente a
gente foi o responsável acrescentando
que está em santos há dois meses atrás x
incêndio gigantesco o que não foi
responsável pela coleta eo tratamento de
todos aqueles efluentes resultantes do
do incêndio vão usar muita água para
apagar incêndio
ela foi contaminada com aquele material
anti incêndio e combustíveis ea gente
contratou é como eu disse para vocês a
minha no a minha busca na verdade é
muito mais pela mudança sistêmica eu
entendi que as empresas têm um papel e
uma responsabilidade na construção da
sociedade e por isso eu montei um
negócio
e aí eu sou também parte e um grande
entusiasta e apoiador do movimento tendo
por um capricho mas consciente que é um
movimento global como shows capitalismo
que busca diferentemente do sistema b e
busca trazer pra gente pra reflexão o
tema da prática das empresas na
sociedade elas têm uma prática mais
responsável e mais consciente é eu acho
fundamental compartilhar com vocês que
que tanto as empresas como os indivíduos
são outros problemas a gente todos
estamos num processo de um caminho de
construção de evolução
então ninguém ninguém o modelo pra
ninguém ninguém está pronto pra ser esse
modelo tá todo mundo nesse caminho de
construção e com isso em mente imaginá
lo
o dalai lama nem o dalai lama nem o
presidente do google depende a
referência que é importante pra você
está nesse ponto de evolução que já não
precisa mais fazer mais nada pra evoluir
então isso vai passar organizações
também e para vocês e para vocês terem
idéia pra você certificada como empresa
ver
precisa responder um questionário que
vai de zero a 200 pontos e quem tem mais
de 80 porque consegue atingir mais de 80
pontos está elegível para certificar é
ea empresa mais bem ranqueada no mundo
só acho que quase 1400 empresas hoje têm
por volta de 160 170 pontos
o que quero dizer com isso a empresa que
talvez todos nós gostaríamos de
trabalhar na empresa modelo ainda tem
muito a fazer para chegar no gabarito
então vamos respeitar o nosso processo é
o nosso tempo que aí é esse olhar é
acolhedor
o nosso caminho é fundamental esse foi
super libertador pra mim eu tenho um
senso crítico muito apurado e acho que é
fundamental esse é um conceito foi super
importante para o meu caminho
um outro conceito importante pra mim foi
entender que somos todos luz e sombra
todos temos incoerências todas as
organizações todos indivíduos todas as
coisas no mundo tem um lado luz e tem um
lado sombra ea gente tem que respeitar
os dois lados mas é uma escolha o lado
você vai dar ouvidos
o procon o lado você vai dedicar energia
de vocês
então essa lista do que é